after producing several videos about
fake quotes that you find attributed to
philosophers specifically to aristotle
and to plato i did a poll and said who
do you want me to do next and one of the
big winners was marcus aurelius the
great stoic writer and emperor there's a
lot of things that get attributed to him
that are actually not by him and then
circulated around on the internet so
we're going to look at 10 and actually a
bonus 11th egregiously fake quotes that
get attributed to marcus aurelius here's
the first one and you've probably seen
this in a lot of places this one got
repeated by the daily stoic everything
we hear is an opinion not a fact
everything we see is a perspective not
the truth and the daily stoic got
suckered just like so many other people
why is this not a genuine marcus
aurelius quote well when you see words
that
really don't show up in ancient thought
like fact that should be a red flag to
you right now there is some sort of
connection to marcus in meditations book
two he says everything is what you
suppose it to be for the words that were
addressed to the cynic monamas are clear
enough and clear to the value of that
saying if one accepts its inner meaning
so far
as this is true so there is some sense
in which there are references to
opinions or perspectives and aurelius
himself will say in book 12 at several
different points everything is opinion
but the word that's being translated
there as opinion is not the usual doxa
or dogmata right it's hupolapsis which
is a very important stoic term which
doesn't really mean opinion as such it
actually means something like assumption
so
you know the key there that marcus wants
to make is that this is all up to us
it's within our power he's not saying
anything about relativism along these
lines that there are no things that we
can agree upon so this is clearly
not a aurelius quotation it's kind of a
garble up and we see that even sites
like the daily stoic can get suckered
into believing and repeating them let's
take a look at the second one this one's
kind of long live a good life if there
are gods and they are just they will not
care how devout you have been but will
welcome you based on the virtues you
have lived by if there are gods but
unjust then you should not want to
worship them if there are no gods then
you will be gone but will have lived a
noble life that will live on in the
memories of your loved ones this is not
by irelias this is a what we can call a
hot mess garble of other things that
marcus says at various points you could
view it as a really awful paraphrase of
what's going on in book two chapter 11
of the meditations where marcus says let
your every action word and thought be
those of one who could depart from life
at any moment but taking your leave of
the human race is nothing to be feared
if the gods exist for they would not
involve you in anything bad if on the
other hand they do not exist or they do
not concern themselves with human
affairs why should i care to go on
living in a world devoid of gods or
devoid of providence that is the closest
we can find to the quote in marcus
aurelius's actual meditations and you
can see that there's quite a difference
there this became popular on the
internet and keeps circulating around
this third quote is a very short one
anger cannot be dishonest it's not
actually by marcus even though he does
say an awful lot of stuff about anger
and quotes other people talking about
anger for example theophrastus the
friend and successor of aristotle who he
quotes in book two of the meditations or
rather cites in the meditations saying
that anger is not as bad as plain old
desire for physical pleasure and he says
that offenses that are committed through
desire are worse or more blamable than
those which are committed through anger
and you could you know read into that if
you wanted to something like anger is
more honest but marcus never actually
says that who does say that well it's
actually coming from a guy named george
robert back who first says it in his
1969 book the intimate enemy and then
repeats it in his co-authored book in
1971 aggression lab the fair fight
training manual
our fourth fake quote is a little bit
longer and also
rather
you could say new agey when you arise in
the morning think of what a precious
privilege it is to be alive to breathe
to think to enjoy
to love and again not by marcus aurelius
who does talk at several points about
what you should do in the morning most
notably in book two where he says remind
yourself when you get up in the morning
that you're gonna face a lot of negative
people and we don't need to go into the
whole quotation there in book five he's
also starting with a first thoughts in
the morning in the morning when you find
yourself unwilling or loathe to rise
have this thought at hand i am a rising
to a human being's work now neither of
these are remotely like what is being
said here breathe think enjoy love a
precious privilege to be alive they're
not completely incompatible with
marcus's thought but it's not marcus's
thought and indeed it comes from a book
or rather a sort of journal thing
entitled for philistines and roy
crofters and this is by an author called
the fra and the entry is actually
under the new thought it attributes this
passage to both epictetus and marcus
aurelius claiming that they teach a
similar gospel to christ who was just
referenced before in that section so
again not a true quote from marcus
aurelius's writings instead we've got a
much more contemporary thing and the
language should show that to you
here's another one that is not by marcus
aurelius but is attributed to him by
somebody else who's quite famous leo
tolstoy and it goes the object in life
is not to be on the side of the majority
but to escape finding oneself in the
ranks of the insane interestingly it's
coming from tolstoy's book be think
yourself but if you go to the 1904
version of it you're not actually going
to find it you've got to go to the
recollections and essays version
translated in 1946 and then you will
find it in
chapter 8. is it by marcus aurelius it
is not where did tolstoy get the idea
that it was we don't know i would like
to point out however that
this does get used in other people's
books for example frank mclin's 2009
marcus aurelius alive where he
attributes this to marcus aurelius and
saying why people like marcus aurelius
and why they get into him so he
attributes it without providing any
citation of the text telling you where
it comes from so he uncritically bought
into it and then
incorporated it into his own book which
also since it was published means that
some editors let it slide through
here we get one that actually does come
from ancient times each day provides its
own gifts now this doesn't come from
marcus aurelius it's not found on his
meditations but it is found in
marshall's epigrams in book eight of
them in the translation by walter
charles allen care and the latin for it
there is omnis hobbit suadona dies each
day provides its own gifts as a great
translation of that or every single day
has its own gifts presumably to offer us
now later we find it being
said or rather written in two
books by
women whose first name is ruth ruth p
friedman and ruth ann
schabacker each day provides its own
gifts by friedman and each day comes
bearing its own gifts followed by untie
the ribbon in ruth and schabacker and
from that it gets circulated around by a
lot of other writers who like that that
sentiment did they take it directly from
marshall we don't really know but it's
not by marcus aurelius
now we get to some really funny fake
quotes and what's funny about them is
that they are coming from a movie script
rather than from the meditations
what we do now echoes in eternity so
this is coming from gladiator and it's
not said by marcus aurelius in gladiator
it is actually said by maximus the main
character
marcus aurelius is kind of uh a bit
player in that movie and you know does
this jibe with things that
that marcus aurelius actually said i
mean he does have some references to
eternity you know for example in book
nine he says loss is nothing else than
change but the universal nature delights
in change and in obedience to her all
things are now done well and from
eternity have been done in like form and
will be such to time without end and
then in book 10 he says whatever is
going to happen to you it was prepared
for you from all eternity and the
implication of causes was from eternity
spinning the threat of your being and of
that which is incident to it so could
there be some sense of like echoes in
eternity well kind of i mean often
marcus is saying if you think about
things in terms of eternity you realize
how little lasting most things including
us are so
this really doesn't fit marcus aurelius
although it is kind of a cool quote for
a movie
this is another quote from gladiator
which is also put in the mouth of
maximus who is going to claim that
marcus aurelius the marcus aurelius
who's a character in the movie said it
death smiles at us all all a man can do
is smile back and this is in an exchange
with commodus marcus aurelius's terrible
son who is you know sort of the arch
rival the antagonist of maximus and so
maximus says i knew a man once who said
and then he repeats the phrase and
komoda says i wondered did your friend
smile at his own death and maximus says
you must know he was your father so he's
saying this is by marcus aurelius but
this is a fictional marcus aurelius who
is part of a
movie now does marcus say things kind of
like that yes he does for example in
meditations book two he says accept
death in a cheerful spirit as nothing
but the dissolution of the elements from
which each living thing is composed but
he's not saying smiling right there and
we can also think about a passage where
there is a reference to smiling pass on
your way with a smiling face under the
smile of him who bids you go this might
be a source of this garbled quotation
that was being tapped by the writers it
doesn't say that death smiles at us
though does it all it says is the one
who bids you go who could be god for all
we know so definitely not by marcus
aurelius the writer of the meditations
but
attributed to a movie character
this quote no man is happy who does not
think himself so is
in part derived from marcus aurelius
it's not a totally fake quote or totally
made up but it's a garbled periphrastic
translation a bad translation right the
better translation for this would be
those who do not observe the movements
of their own minds must of necessity be
unhappy and so it's not a reference to
being happy it's actually a reference to
being unhappy kako daimonine right to to
be unhappy to have a bad spirit a spirit
of badness so to speak and
he's not saying that you're not happy
because you don't realize that you're
happy he's saying that if you're not
observing what's going on in your own
mind soul personality you are going to
be unhappy so not a completely fake
quote but something that isn't what
marcus is saying
we have another similarly sloppy
translation of what it is that marcus
does say here a man's worth is no
greater than his ambitions now if you
actually read the greek text there is no
reference there whatsoever to ambition
which would be philotymia instead
there's references to oxios and oxia
things of value things of worth and a
better translation of this would be
every person is worth just so much as
the things are worth about which they
busy themselves espoodakane
right the things that they are focused
upon the things that they take seriously
so this tells us something about how
people value themselves and other things
but it doesn't tell us anything about
ambitions
finally here's a bonus 11th quote the
opinion of 10 000 men is of no value if
none of them know anything about the
subject and again the language itself
should put us on guard there are
references to the opinions of the many
but there are no references whatsoever
to 10 000 people in the meditations
there are references to 10 000 but for
years or for the numbers of cavalry and
infantry that got killed on a
battlefield where does this one come
from we don't really know but it's
definitely not by marcus
so there you have it a set of fake
quotes that are constantly being
reposted recirculated treated as if
they're true and now you know that
they're fake and in many cases you know
where they come from as usual i'm gonna
close by giving you some suggestions
should always exercise healthy suspicion
you shouldn't be reposting fake quotes
if you know that they're fake and you
probably shouldn't even justify them by
saying well they're true in some way no
they're just fake quotes so don't do it
and when you see people posting things
demand the sources say where is that
actually coming from in marcus aurelius
or whoever else and if they can't tell
you where there's a good chance that it
could be a fake quote i would also
suggest checking out the website
cententei antiqua they have a whole
bunch of articles about fake quotes and
they're doing some really great work in
calling out the
people who are are constantly you could
say polluting the internet with these
you